Brittney's fierce is twirling off the
haters literally on Sunday Britt shared
a video on Instagram giving fans a look
at her over-the-top Christmas tree guys
this is what my Christmas tree looks
like this year like guys it's huge you
better watch out you better not cry but
of course it wouldn't be a Britney
Spears insta post without her signature
twirls and poses Santa Claus is coming
to town
and while the clip was all kinds of cute
festive holiday fun it's the comments
section that really caught fans
attention the 38 year old popstar
straight up called out the trolls quote
I love sharing with you all but it's
been hard to keep wanting to share
because people say the meanest things if
you don't like a post just keep it to
yourself
and unfollowed that person there's no
reason to ever go out of your way to
make mean comments and bully people
Britt ended her message encouraging
people to stay happy and nice this
holiday season I just want to be a happy
person Britt's little sis Jamie Lynn
Spears showed her support posting hard
emojis in the comments
well Britt Britt's boyfriend Sam asghari
showed his love writing it's so easy to
cyberattack and hide behind their phones
and write mean comments but when they
run into you in real life all of a
sudden they act like they have been such
a huge fan and want a picture Britney's
post comes just weeks after she
celebrated her 38th birthday your
birthday wish today on your birthday
at the time a source told ET that she is
doing incredibly well and is in a very
stable place at the moment the source
added that right now her life is all
about family and spending time with Sam
and her kids and how's your relationship
with the kids
it's absolutely daddy now yeah yeah we
went to Disneyland everything's great
but our source says don't expect
anything to change for Britt and Sam
anytime soon quote he doesn't want to
rush to marriage life is amazing he
wants the best for her and they're just
enjoying their time together Sam loves
her and so does his family I mean
absolutely this is something that every
couple should do that's the whole point
of a relationship we're a family happy
families met yes what does your mom like
sisters aren't here I have three sisters
oh and they're like yeah sounds bring
home breeding for conspiracy dinner's
long out a lot of times you know we've
been together for three years my
sister's love her my family loves her my
mom lives in another country when she
was here she met her I loved seeing
Brittany happy and honestly I think we
should all follow Brittany's advice be
happy and nice and twirl off those
haters of course you can count on UT to
bring you all the latest Brittany news
so make sure to keep it locked right
here until next time I'm Hallie Stevens
and I'll be twirling off those haters
[Music]